build-it draw play it Vsauce this is
your home for some of the coolest
creations from everyday people
this is filled chris built a vapor
display that creates floating images
like this one of Princess Leia his
device is made of drinking straws PVC
pipe and a humidifier and it creates a
thin sheet of water vapor that catches
light from a projector to turn the page
of his newspaper in an absurd and
inventive manner joseph Hirscher built
this Rube Goldberg machine that looks
like something straight out of pee-wee's
big adventure utilize boiling water and
even a hamster to successfully turn the
page find the link below to watch the
whole thing in motion after taking a
poll to find out which parts of female
stars women most admired an image was
built combining them into what's being
called the ultimate celebrity so yeah
deviant artist Francis gray built this
custom alien versus Predator chess set
it features different classes of both
the Xenomorphs and the trophy hunting
predators and the board itself was
inspired by the pyramid temple in the
aliens vs. predator movie
Myka creates hand-drawn animations that
focus on unified state of growth and
decay he also writes and performs his
own music for the animations shannon has
an incredible portrait channel and this
video shows off his ability to draw with
both hands his right hand is his
dominant hand but his ability to draw
with his left to help create this
charcoal tribute to Shawshank Redemption
is amazing
now some entries from super punches
James Bond fan art contest
finally a Toronto couple and a handful
of volunteers spent many sleepless
nights stacking moving and organizing
books at tyke bookstore to create this
animation like mr. Solid Snake's 7:45
recreates popular video game music and
pop songs using floppy drives
here's his rendition of Party Rock
Anthem by LMFAO
Ryan used an n64 the power of video
editing to make his WTF beat video Game
of Thrones collides with the commodore
64 in this chiptune track find the
download link for the song and the video
linked below
finally there's this incredible music
video for a track called surprise
submit your own be dps as a private
message here on youtube or share them
with everyone over at
facebook.com/vsaucetwo
for watching
Oh